okay in this problem A 250,000-gallon
detention Basin is constructed in order
to receive runoff from a nearby parking
lot the sewer leading to the parking lot
can handle a Max flow of 7 cubic feet
per second during a given storm the
average discharge from the parking lot
through the sewer and into the Basin was
2 cubic feet per second how long in
hours would this particular storm be
able to last assuming a uniform
intensity before the Basin had no
capacity left and flooding occurred
elsewhere so this problem is a basic
unit unit conversion problem and all we
need to do is use the information that
it's given us as well as the
understanding that Q
equals volume over time so we can prove
that real quick just by looking at the
units so Q is cubic feet per second
volume is cubic feet time is seconds
these match
up and all we have to do is rearrange
this equation to find what the question
is asking for which is time so t = v
over
Q we've already been given our V that's
the
250,000 gon detention
Basin and we also have been given our Q
it is going to be 2 cubic feet per
second ignore the 7 ft cubic feet per
second that was given just to throw you
off this question is asking for how long
this particular storm would have been
able to last during the
storm where the flow was 2 cubic feet
per second we don't care currently about
what the max flow of the sewer could be
so the first step is just going to be
taking the area we were given and
converting
it so we have
250,000
gallons and according to our unit
conversions in the reference manual 1
cubic foot equal
748 gallons and this will give
us
[Music]
22.5 cubic feet
step
two um knowing t = v over Q we just need
to solve
so we have our volume at the top here
and we've been given our Q in the
problem
so
22.5 cubic feet
over 2 cubic feet per second
and this gives us just about
16,7
111.2
seconds all we have to do now is convert
that into hours so 16
71.2 seconds
Time 1
Min over 60 seconds Time 1
hour over 60
Minutes gives us
4.6
hours and there we go that's all there
is to do this problem it's worth keeping
in mind that if you had picked 7even
cubic feet per second because you
weren't paying attention um the answer
of 1.3 is what you would have come out
to and the problem asks that too so it's
just an or gives that as an answer as
well um so just a reminder that the PE
will sometimes give the correct answers
to the incorrect variables just as
another way of throwing you off and
making you think that you reach the
problem uh correct so this is just all
about trying to make sure that we pick
the correct terms and we understand
exactly what the problem's asking for
since that's what it takes to pass the
exam but yeah that's it for this problem